- I'm so stocked.
We're all stoked, everybody loves
The Office even four thousand years later.
- Yeah.
- It's kind of impressive though
like still people are just
now cause the Netflix as well.
Like my son he's 13 and
he just told me last week,
he's like gone through so many episodes.
He's going through the whole things now,
he loves it.
- Yeah.
- It's like bringing a
whole new life to it.
- You know we kind of
crush it at middle schools.
(audience laughs)
Like really, we do.
Like I was touring a middle school
and they were like can you
not go in the classrooms
cause the kids were like.
- [Jenna] They were distracted.
- Yeah, middle schools!
- I feel like the show is in some ways
even more popular then when it was on
- Oh yeah.
- When it was airing live on NBC
and I think it's because of streaming,
you can binge it.
You can watch it whenever you want to now,
there's the internet.
- There's the internet!
There's that.
- There was no Instagram when
we were filming The Office!
- Isn't that crazy?
- I think about that
with my career like what
has happened in the, you know,
the span of like with
social media and everything.
- Yeah.
- That's insane but
it's brought a whole new
life to it and it's such great writing,
great characters, it's just
such a phenomenal thing.
So you started a new podcast and basically
tell everybody what your Office Ladies
is a podcast but tell 'em what you do.
- All right.
- You go 'cause you're good at this part.
- Every week we watch
an episode of the office
and then we break it
down and we tell you all
of our behind the scenes
memories, stories, and trivia.
Everything we can remember.
We reach out to cast
members and crew members
and we give you all the scoop.
- All the scoop.
- We started from the beginning
with episode one and we're going in order.
- All the way through.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Yeah.
- But this week your podcast the episode
is about the fire episode right?
- Yes!
Oh, that was a really fun one because that
was the first episode that we shot
outside of the offices so we were,
it was an exterior shoot.
The fire alarm goes off
and we all have to go out
to the parking lot and there was this,
we're gonna talk about
this on the podcast.
- I know but I just
want you guys to notice,
do you see how Jenna is?
Here's the synopsis,
this is what happened .
- Yeah, it gives some context.
- And then I'm like that's
the one with the bug,
remember the bug?
- It's like so different the personality,
that's why you go together.
- So there was this giant bug
that started attacking us.
I mean it was very large,
it was unusually large .
- Listen, it zeroed in
on me, I don't know why.
I think, I don't know,
maybe because I look
less threatening 'cause I'm so short.
- 'cause you're tinier?
- I'm tiny, but it kept
like buzzing my head.
I don't know about you, I
don't like anything by my ear.
Don't get by my ear!
- There goes your social life.
There goes making out.
- Okay, all right, there's one
person who can get by my ear.
- You know what, I've
been on stage on tour
and they attack me 'cause
I'm in a spot light.
So if you're outside in a
shed tour, yeah they just.
And there's these like
prehistoric ones down in Florida.
- That's what this was!
It was from olden times.
- I was like is this a dinosaur?
- Yeah, it was the size of a Buick.
It was like and I got,
we started doing a joke
that it was gonna like pick me up
and take me away cause
it landed on my shoulder.
- I wish I could make that joke.
(Audience Laughs)
Things I'll never say.
No, but that's amazing.
- John Krasinski does great impressions
of people or things or whatever.
He's an amazing impressionist.
So he started doing an
impression of Angela
being carried away by
the bug and it was like.
- It was so funny.
- Anyway you guys it was hilarious.
Make john Krasinski do the giant bug
thing for you when you run into him.
- I will make him do it, I will get him
on the show and make him, demand it.
- Yes, and then make him
do his boom operator.
Boom operator, he does
a great boom operator.
- And he does a great Muppet.
- [Kelly] These are random gifts.
- Oh, he does a really good Muppet.
- These are random talents.
I can not wait to meet him.
- I know.
- John right now is like thanks ladies.
All my bits.
- You actually, you found
it was from your first table read, right?
You found a photo from your
first table read that y'all did?
- Yes!
Yes, our casting director Alison Jones
brought her camera and
she took a Polaroid of us
and she gave one to each of us
and I saved mine all these years.
- That's so cool!
We do Polaroids on this show, I love it.
It just looks vintage and cool.
- I didn't get one 'cause
I wasn't there that day.
- She hadn't been cast yet!
- I hadn't been cast yet.
I'm okay with it.
- Aren't you, Angela you tried out right?
Whenever you were auditioning,
you auditioned out for her part right?
- I auditioned for the
role of Pam and I went
in you guys and I thought I did so great.
And it was a big room.
- You did, you got the
job, just a different one.
- I got a different job but it was
a room full of people and
there's a moment where Micheal is fake
firing Pam in front of Ryan the temp
to like pull a prank and Pam starts to cry
and calls him a jerk and I called him like
a jerk and every started
laughing and I was like
I don't think that was
suppose to be a laugh.
I think I missed something.
And then of course you see this
vulnerable moment that Pam,
as much as she hates
that job, she needs it
and Jenna did such an
amazing job portraying
that but so they said
I didn't get the part
'cause I was a little too feisty.
- You were raised in
Texas so it's understood.
- I know, listen, I will call
someone jerk if they're a jerk.
- Ill call someone something else, yeah.
- [Angela] Maybe.
- It depends on the moment.
- But then they brought
me back they said hey,
we've got kind of a judge-y
, snarky lady in accounting.
And I said okay!
- That calls amazing, hey you
know you'd be perfect for.
- Yeah, the snarky lady.
- The snarky lady.
You're both busy moms.
I'm a busy mom as well, I get it.
But do you ever give each other advice,
you know when we go to that dark place?
- Well, sometimes.
We parent very similarly
- Thank goodness!
- Yeah, on of the ways
our friendship works
is we have similar values in that way.
But Angela had her daughter
before I had my son
and so there was this period of time
where she was a mother and I wasn't.
- That's real different.
- That was, we made it through.
But I use to call her
up and I would be like
"Ang, meet me out of
margaritas at 10 o'clock!"
- 10 o'clock?
- No, momma's in bed.
- Momma's been in bed four hours
like what are you talking about?
I was like Jenna I haven't
had a margarita in two years.
- Well that's you first problem.
(audience laughs)
I mean.
- I corrected that but I was
in the weeds for a little bit.
- You can make a margarita at home.
No, but have your kids
seen The Office yet?
Do they watch it right now?
- Mine have not.
Mine are still,
I have an eight year
old and a five year old.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- And my kids hadn't seen it either,
except this year they're in fifth grade.
Two of them are in fifth
grade and all their friends
watched it over the summer
and so my mom was like,
I mean my daughter was like,
mom can I please finally watch The Office?
And I was like okay and I was at the time
watching Healthcare for the podcast
and I was like why don't
you watch Healthcare
and she was like mom,
what's an anal fissure?
(audience laughs)
- Oh my god, I love this conversaton.
- [Angela] And I was like
- Is that when you say go ask your dad?
- Well no, I was just like it's a real,
and she goes is that real?
I was like yes.
Um, fast forward.
So, I don't know, so yeah
she's watching The Office now.
It's not all anal fissures.
(audience laughs)
- Its not.
- It's not.
- So out of all, it's not!
So out of all the episodes what scene was,
for each of you, was the hardest to shoot?
- We were talking about this
because I mean there's hardest,
emotionally hardest because
we were laughing so hard so,
where should we start?
- I think hardest because we were laughing
so hard was the dinner party episode.
We just laughed our way through that week.
We ruined so many takes
the bunch of us on that.
Yeah but then hardest
emotionally was just the whole
episode where we were
saying good bye to Steve.
When we sing to him, when I had my,
I mean we were just
crying through everything
and when I had my good
bye to him at the airport.
That was really rough, yeah.
- We were just so teary
all week and Will Ferrell
was a guest star that week
and I was standing next
to him for a scene and he goes I feel
like I'm at like a funeral but I'm suppose
to be funny at the funeral.
- oh my gosh.
- And I was like oh, that must be really
hard to be around all of us.
But yeah, and then also
there was awkward things
that were hard 'cause they were awkward
like I had to toss a cat into a ceiling.
- [Kelly] You really did toss a cat?
Like a real cat?
- [Angela] I mean, look at that.
Oh no, it was
- I mean I remember that but I thought
maybe it was a fake cat.
- Oh, well there was a
- Parts of it were fake.
- Well not part of the animal.
- No, but I mean parts of the
shot were with a fake cat.
- Yes, but I had to like in the scene when
like everyone's going crazy and like
Kevin has a copier and he's like,
I had to like take a cat out of a drawer.
Which I guess my character's kept
a cat in her drawer all these years.
- That's not creepy at all, fine.
- And the cat is huge, this
wasn't like a little cat,
it was like enormous.
- It was a heifer.
- It was, it was like a heifer.
Bless her heart.
- [Kelly] Bless her heart.
- Bless her heart, she's a heifer.
Anyway, so I had to get
this big cat and then
I had to like swing it
and do this whole thing.
- And you're little!
- And I'm little!
And it's like (imitates cat meowing)
it was like not into it.
And then everyone was screaming
so that was difficult.
- Or awesome.
- [Angela] Or awesome, yeah.
- So The Office is coming
to the NBC streaming
service right now so
would you do a reboot?
Would y'all do it?
- We talk about this all the time,
we wanna do a reunion special.
Like a reason that everyone in The Office
has to reunite for some reason
like a one time special episode.
- Like a movie, like a reunion movie.
- Yeah, because I think
a reboot would be hard.
I think at the end of
the series I mean spoiler
alert for anyone who's still in the middle
of it but some of the people don't end up
staying at the paper company anymore.
They move on, they move
away and so to manufacture
some reason why we're
all working there again
I think would be odd but
I think there is a reason
that we could all reunite
in some other way.
So that's what we're
- We have some ideas.
- That's what we want, call us!
- Call us NBC, email us.
- I think it would be so good,
like I said it's just got such a new life.
Like people are, like of a younger age
are getting into these characters.
It's really cool.
- And on a selfish level,
I would like to work
with all those people again, I'd like
to have us all in a room together.
- It's such a great
chemistry, great vibe, yeah.
- I teared up when I got here
because your security guy,
Joseph, outside did security
for The Office for seven years.
We saw him everyday.
- We gave Joseph a big hug.
- We gave him a big hug.
He use to help me when
my daughter came to set,
I had like a little, you know,
the little pink car you push your kid
around in and it's really loud.
- And everyone loves you.
- Everyone loves you.
I would like push her around and Joseph
would like help me take
it out and set it out
and he's just a sweetheart.
But I would love to see everyone again.
- We might have to steal Joseph
for that week of shooting.
- [Kelly] That's okay.